a video that has two million impressions
should be getting a lower click-through
rate than if it has a thousand
Impressions yeah so you can't compare
them what's a good reach well what
category are we in right because it
depends the reach of a heavywise can be
different than a reach of a six foot Guy
versus reach of a five foot guy is gonna
be different reach I usually do in fives
and ones so 50 to 100 100 to 500 500 or
a thousand thousand to five thousand
five thousand to ten thousand ten
thousand fifty thousand and you group
those so if you have a thousand to five
thousand Impressions that's one group of
videos then look at the click-through
rates relative to each other and see the
lower half that's what we gotta fix